in this victory spotlight we'll be going
over all sorts of use of ways to work
with data and bigquery a great way to
learn is by doing so in this episode
we'll show you how to get started with
the bigquery sandbox
[Music]
big query sandbox gives you free access
to trial bigquery and use the UI without
providing a credit card or using a
billing account it's a quick way to get
started and try out some of the concepts
we'll be talking about in this series to
get started click on the link in the
description below if you're a new Google
cloud user you will need to create an
account and a project by following the
prompts once the project is created you
will be redirected to the bigquery
console where you'll see sandbox in the
top left hand corner if you're a
returning Google cloud user create a new
project by selecting the project drop
down your new projects may be created
with a default billing account if that's
the case go into the billing account
management page and select disable
billing by following the instructions
also linked below then use a search bar
within the console to head to bigquery
make sure your new project is selected
in the project drop-down and there you
will also see sandbox in the top
left-hand corner now that you're in the
bigquery sandbox you're ready to start
querying that's all it takes to get set
up because you aren't charged for using
the bigquery sandbox there are a few
caveats mainly any tables or views that
you create will expire after 60 days
you're also limited to 10 gigabytes of
storage and one terabyte of data
processed each month still a lot of room
to play around with these numbers may
change so be sure to check the
documentation for the latest information
other than that you can easily start
working with public datasets loading in
your own data and running some queries
bakery provides publicly available
datasets for anyone analyzed covering a
variety of data types from historical
weather to taxi trips taken in New York
City to analyze public data just click
on the add data button on the left hand
side to see a list of the publicly
available datasets that you already have
available as a quick example let's use
the project sunroof public dataset so
you can see how much sunlight hits your
roof in a year in this sample query
we're averaging the amount of sunlight
per US state and ordering
the top three states by the highest
sunlight potential as you can see the
top three states are New Mexico Arizona
and Nevada that's a lot of sunshine
don't worry if you're not sure how we
built this query in the next episode
we'll explain this in more detail and
break down how to query your data look
out for the next episode of bigquery
spotlight and remember stay curious
[Music]
you